Donald Trump another 14th candidate for
the Republican nomination for president
made the statement that we have a porous
border and that rapists and criminal are
coming right through the border and
that's why we've got to build a fence
paid for by Mexico and he's what number
one involves now isn't that interesting
that extreme position at least with the
Republicans is getting all that support
that puts in the number one position
that the fact is the immigration rate
illegal immigration the rate has gone
down by practically a half since 2009
illegal immigrants are going back to
Mexico we hear the term of Ferguson
which represents what's been happening
all over the United States in various
different cities Baltimore Wisconsin
Staten Island where young male
african-americans unarmed are shot down
and killed by law enforcement officers
so there's another example the racial
profiling of Arab Americans in this
country because they look like
terrorists that's precisely what
happened to japanese-americans during
the Second World War we happen to look
like the people that bombed Pearl Harbor
we japanese-americans are very very
mindful of the power of the media right
prior to the Second World War we were
the Asians were depicted as inscrutable
vicious cunning and every minority group
has been characterized by stereotypes
and that's been perpetuated by the media
there be television movies radio comic
books all these various forms have
strengthened those stereotypes and when
it's inflamed by an individual or a
current event then the country is swept
up by that that hysteria
[Music]